Tyrese Maxi 18 points dished out four
assists as well and he is with us from
Philadelphia I told there he is hey
Tyrese good to have you with us thanks
for stopping by uh I would describe this
as a workmanlike win from the 76ers
tonight it felt like it was never really
in doubt from about Midway through the
third quarter from our vantage point
from where you sit what went right
tonight yeah I mean we was able to get
stops get out and transition um you know
coach nurse has really been on us about
getting to the paint and transition and
kind of passing out so early twos or
early threes and uh that's been good for
us so far tyres congratulations make
sure you say hi to your mom and dad for
me as well Young fella uh talk talk a
little bit about what all the the chaos
that's been kind of going on with with
the James Harden situation and uh I know
you guys worked a lot I know he was was
good for you in terms of maybe the skill
development but how was that having to
go through something like that cuz that
had to be new for you right you you
never probably experienced something
like that before you know what's funny
sadly it's not it's not new you know we
went we went through it my second year
so oh but it happens you know it's part
of it it's part of the game it's part of
it and uh you know shouts out to James
before I say anything he was really
professional uh he came in he still
helped guys he was in shape so when he
practiced he practiced great um you know
so shout out to him he he kept it really
cool and it was no distraction from him
so it was actually really good and then
the team I think Nick nurse Joel Tobias
the guys that's been here
uh we did a good job of just keeping the
main thing the main thing so everybody
was really focused on uh trying to get
better it's coach nurse first year so we
trying to learn schemes learn how he
thinks um I think it was really good so
uh there wasn't much of a distraction at
all honestly tyres coming into this
season with Nick nurse has he spoken to
you about trusting you more and giving
you more opportunities it seems like
your uptick is is really shown the work
that you put in and and the consistency
that you've had over the years through
different positions as Nick nurse had
that conversation with you yeah I think
when he first got the job uh we didn't
know who was going to be on our team we
didn't know what the the James situation
was but the first thing that he told me
was be myself go out there and be myself
he knew uh he knows what I could do he
was very uh he said in Toronto uh he saw
a lot of things that I was able to do so
he wanted me to go out there and do
those same type things and just be
extremely aggressive while doing it and
U he he says he trust me on the ball
making plays and every single play as a
skip pass um pocket pass to joah and
then being able to score the ball well
he wants me to be more aggressive so I'm
trying first time you've had a coaching
change in your young NBA career four
games into the regular season what do
you know about Nick nurse that you
didn't when training camp
started he loves music he really loves
music we a little bit right yeah he
plays I think the piano guitar he has a
lot of instruments honestly but uh he
just really loves music I that's the one
thing that that I feel like um that I
learned about him and then also he his
mind he thinks the game so differently
um he's able to just throw things out
there um he tries things on the Fly and
you kind of just have to go with it he
said we before training camp started he
wanted us all to have an open mind uh
every single game is going to be
different things that he's going to try
some's going to work some not going to
work and he just wanted us to be
open-minded about it if it works we'll
keep it in our playoff toolbox and if it
doesn't he said he'll flush it down the
toilet and and we'll move on yeah we
we've seen that over the years he'll try
some stuff there's no question about it
Tyrese appreciate you stopping by good
luck and continued good health to you in
the Sixers all right Jo I appreciate it
y'all be safe